Мені здається аполітичною може бути тільки людина, яка ніколи не зіштовхувалась з війною.
Зараз фашизмом називають такі явища як любов до України, таке враження, що українці взагалі не мають права любити свою країну...
Що українець - це такий червонощокий козак з вареником на вилці, а поруч з ним молодиця така сидить і горілочка,  і сальце. А українці вони взагалі не такі.
"Євробачення" для мене -  така цікава подія.
Пам'ятаю свою першу згадку про нього, коли я побачила по телевізору випадково, як Руслана перемогла в 2004 році.
Я тоді якраз в лікарні лежала і вийшла,  побачила телевізор на посту у медсестер і там якраз цей момент, де Руслана стоїть, і вона перемогла.
Я подумала, що нічого собі, Україна перемогла на "Євробаченні". Це так класно.
І такі відчуття гордості за нашу країну. І те що ми їдемо представляти Україну на “Євробаченні” -  якась магія.
Не хочеться думати про “Євробачення” як про якусь політичну арену,
але звісно, цей підтекст він буде, адже те що відбувається між країнами -  від цього не втекти.
Навіть зараз у нас більшість людей запитує не про те:  як ви ставитесь до конкуренції з Литвою,  чи Швейцарією,  чи Австралією.
Нам завжди ставлять питання про Росію.
Мені здається,  що аполітичною може бути тільки людина, яка ніколи не зіштовхувалась з війною
і в якої ніхто не загинув на війні і яка не розуміє, що там відбувається. А вона є і там досі жертви.
Ми коли на фронт приїхали і нам сказали, що підемо виступати до солдатів, то ми подумали: що у нас немає жодної пісні про війну і такого патріотичного.
Але коли ми приїхали, солдат каже: “Заспівайте народну пісню, як мені бабуся співала”.
І ми співали народні пісні і це було найкраще для них, бо співати солдатам про війну це не правильно,
особливо,  коли про війну пишуть ті, хто ніколи на ній не був.
Ми дуже раді будь-якій публіці, але ми пережили період передвиборчої кампанії і відмовляли всім,
адже ми не хочемо підтримувати людей, яким ми не довіряємо і ми взагалі намагаємось тримати репутацію в чистоті.
Нам запропонували алкоголь рекламувати і ми теж відмовляємось від цього, бо це не співпадає з нашою філософією.
Чорнобиль і коронавірус це результат того, що людина несвідомо сама собі завдає шкоди,  і не лише собі, але і навколишньому середовищу,
і це говорить про те, що якщо ми не зупинимось, якщо ми не переосмислюємо свого існування на планеті і не перестанемо варварськи ставитись до природи,
до всього,  що нас оточує, то буде Чорнобиль, буде коронавірус і наша планета перетвориться на суцільну техногенну катастрофу.
І ми б хочемо підтяни тему того, що людство має замислитись.
Ми зараз говоримо про Чорнобиль в контексті аварії і техногенної катастрофи,
а насправді ще одна катастрофа відбулась - ми втратили великий пласт культури, і мене це зачепило.
І я це намагаюсь передати це в свої творчості.
І якраз обряд шум він теж побутував у Чорнобильській зоні,  тому у нас там і з'являється кадр з саркофагом,
бо мені здається, що якраз у чорнобильському лісі там максимально відбувається відновлення природи.
Ми кілька днів тому їздили туди і бачили як природа бере своє, як пробивається крізь будинки, пробиває асфальт.
І скільки там птахів, тварин... Треба просто усвідомити, що планета без людей може існувати, а люди без планети - ні.
Зараз фашизмом називають такі явища як любов до України, таке враження, що українці взагалі не мають права любити свою країну,
бо якщо ти кажеш що любиш її - то це вважається фашизмом. А що погано в тому, що ти любиш, те місце в якому ти живеш?
Мені здається в цьому немає нічого поганого. Фашизм це набагато страшніша річ.
Російські журналісти з нами не зв'язувались, вони там самі придумують свої історії. Інколи нас тегають якісь єврофанські пабліки.
У нас  до речі дуже багато слухачів у Росії, вони нам пишуть приємні слова, пишуть українською мовою навіть і багато в Сибірі таких.
І там пишуть, що ми ваші  і що тут багато ваших.. Там же багато українців залишилось.
І ми не можемо не любити їх тільки через те, що вони проживають на тій території.
Була дивна ситуація,  коли мені написали студенти, не пригадую назву закладу, але це як наше Київське Суворовське училище, де військові вчаться.
І мені прислали відео, де 15-річні хлопчики у формі співають нашого “Солов’я”.
І мені здається, може, вони послухають українську музику і подумають, чи варто йти на нас з війною.
Співачку MANIZHA  я знаю дуже давно і коли я побачила, що вона приймає участь у нацвідборі, то подумала, що якщо вона переможе, то буде дуже класно,
бо вона дуже позитивна, несе добро. А а потім я побачила, що вона виграла і зайшла послухати її пісню і дуже здивувалася,
бо ця пісня не схожа на те що вона робила до цього, на всі її кліпи і на всю її музику,  але про пісню нічого не можу сказати.
Ті теми,  які вона зачіпала у своїй творчості, це максимальний заклик любити одне одного і робити добро.
Я не скажу, що ця пісня несе негативні меседжі,  але просто не відповідає тому, що вона робила до цього. Ось і все.
Я пам'ятаю як ввели квоти, то всі масово почали писати українською мовою,  але пісня написана просто,
щоб було, вона ніколи не резонує в людей сильно, як пісня, яка написана по-чесному,
тому з'явилося багато українськомовних пісень, які просто наримовані, де просто купа красивих українських слів.
І взагалі  мене дивують пости тих,  хто пише, чому ми слухаємо російськомовне лайно,  але ж ми самі не підтримуємо себе,
ми самі не підтримуємо український контент, а йому дуже сильно треба підтримка…
У нас неймовірна кількість народних пісень, які більшість людей навіть інколи не чула.
Ми інколи з Ігорем починаємо співати, бо він теж фольклорист, і люди кажуть: “О,  така гарна пісня, чому ми її ніколи не чули”.
Бо в нас в основному “А мій милий вареники хоче…”, або “Ой, на горі два дубки” і по цьому судять про український фольклор
і тому у них складається враження,  що український фольклор це щось під чарочку чи баянчик...
І ця модель дуже довго багатьма колективами популяризувалась. Що українець - це червонощокий козак з вареником на вилці
і поруч з ним модолиця  сидить і горілочка і сальце. А українці вони взагалі не такі.
Ми глибший народ і те,  що нам багато років нав'язували таку модель,  не означає, що ми маємо погодитись з нею.